you
[Music]
awesome um yeah so my name is Hilary
Parker thanks so much for coming
I am super honored to be here this has
been a really fun conference with a ton
of great energy so that's been really
cool so yeah I want to talk about using
data effectively and sort of moving
beyond there's sort of people talk about
data science and they talk about how
data science is an art and so I want to
sort of move beyond that terminology so
I'm going to talk about that today and
just for a little background about me I
am a data scientist at stitch fix I also
have a podcast not so standard
deviations and I've just kind of been
involved with our community for the past
decade plus so so yeah I want to talk
about things that I've sort of learned
from all these different things and
ideas I've been able to develop with my
co-host Roger on the podcast so just a
little bit of context about stitch fix
because I'm gonna use stitch fix later
as examples some examples of my work
there so stitch fix is a personally
personal styling service so the idea is
that you come to our websites to tricks
comm and you sign up so you fill out you
know for the types of clothes you want
and the idea is that you answer a bunch
of questions about your style we call it
like a style profile both during
onboarding and then other various points
in time and then from your perspective
you sign up you fill out this
information and then some period of time
later you get a box with five things in
it and those are five pieces of clothing
that we think you're gonna like and then
you kind of keep what you want and then
you send back the rest and so those
those items are handpicked by a stylist
but what's happening behind the scenes
and the reason we have a data science
team of 120 data scientist is that
what's happening in the background is
that we have a bunch of inventory using
the data from your style profile we will
sort that inventory and determine like
what what clothes do we think you're
most likely to like and then we so
order those so we did this kind of you
know machine learning that's all those
graphs and things that are happening we
create a list of algorithmic
recommendations those go in front of the
human stylist and then that person
selects what clothes they think they
should send you so it's called like a
human in the loop problem or like you
know augmented workflow so yeah it's a
super fun problem and I really enjoy it
so you know kind of zooming back out the
point of this talk or like what I really
want to talk about is the way that we do
data science and all of us are here at
this conference because we really care
about you know doing data science well
and I love this kind of paradigm from
the art for data science book about what
it looks like for us especially you know
our users to like participate in this
data analysis data science thing so the
idea is that you you know you have a
data set you import it you have to tidy
it and then you have this sort of like
playful box of modeling the data
transforming it visualizing it and then
you know being inspired or learning new
things from that process and going
through and you know kind of cycling
through and like learning as you go and
then eventually you sort of you know
take the exit ramp from that and you
figure out some way of communicating
what you've learned to another person
and of course the purpose of this
graphic is that a lot of the are
packages and the tidy verse are meant to
address different parts of this stage
right so you have like deep liar and
tidier for sort of shaping and tidying
the data you have a bunch of things for
visualizing transforming and even
communicating with our markdown and you
know various other tools and so if you
if you attend the like any sort of talk
about this from heavily or others the
idea is that oh actually you know this
tidy stuff we don't like to talk about
it but it's actually a huge amount of
the work right so you kind of like have
this little or you know the fun part
that we want to talk about is that kind
of fun exploratory analysis and the
communication afterwards but actually
tidying is this huge amount of the job
that none of us like to talk about right
so um like one thing I love about this
paradigm and sort of the way that the
art studio team and Hadley directly have
talked about it is that the idea that
building the framework of building the
tidy verse and this sort of a
opinionated API layer about what the
data should look like and kind of how
you should be parsing results is that
it's really about creating fluency and
expression for that sort of playful
cyclical you know modeling visualizing
transforming the data etc and so this
was a quote way back in 2013 from Hadley
where he says you know we may find that
the two bottlenecks in a data analysis
are what you want to do and how to tell
your computer to do that a lot of my
existing work has been more about how to
make it easier to express what you want
and I sort of bolded Express because it
is this idea of like a fluent language
and so when I think about the the way
that we talk about doing data analysis I
was at a talk by this person Grady Booch
who's IBM research and he talked a lot
about how like everything is the system
deep down and I was really inspired
about by that because I realized you
know when we talk about doing a data
analysis this graph really represents
like a mini production system right
where you're having data come in you're
doing something to it but then at the
end you want to have a report come out
and so really every time we're doing a
data analysis we're building a little
mini production system that we want to
work effectively and we want it to work
we want to be able to build it quickly
because building the system isn't
exactly what we want to be doing we want
to be doing that kind of creative fun
data analysis part and so I felt like I
learned this especially well when I
moved to a more kind of machine learning
production type job because a lot of the
concepts I'd cared so much about
reproduce reproducibility in this sort
of data analysis production system and I
realized that all those concepts like
directly translated to machine learning
productions
so so I think like thinking about our
work as system design is really helpful
and one of the reasons it's really
helpful is because other groups have
already thought a lot about system
design so there's a lot that we can
learn from them and last year two years
ago at this conference I gave a talk
related to this about what we can learn
from like specifically the devops world
and the operations world I have up here
a book called the field guide to
understanding human error and the whole
idea there is that like when someone has
an error in a data analysis or like if
some sort of catastrophic error happens
in a different system the especially in
the operations world when they're
dealing with systems that like a like an
airplane flying or some other kind of
like high important food system and they
have a very disciplined way about going
about talking about when a failure
happens in that system and kind of the
old school world was like oh this was
due to human error but the people who
think about this all the time realized
that that was sort of disincentivizing
for people surfacing when a system was
breaking because it seemed like like
people would be a worried about like
being fired or being judged of being bad
at their job if there was a system
failure and that's like the opposite of
what you want when you are trying to
keep airplanes flying safely and so they
developed this whole thing about
blameless post-mortems and I could go on
a lot about how great these are but the
idea is to kind of approach the work
like if an error occurs it's not your
personal fault it's more like the system
was failing you and you had good
intentions you wanted to run an analysis
that worked and it didn't and so how can
we change the system so that in the
future it works for you
the other thing that groups who do a lot
of system design think about are sort of
opinionated frameworks so like one
example would be Ruby on Rails for web
frameworks where instead of just saying
hey you can do whatever you want
you know every time you're designing
this system you're starting from scratch
and thinking through all the kind of
micro decisions instead it's like okay
let's kind of have our opinionated way
of setting up this system and then save
our kind of creative energy for the
things that we feel like are really
worth it and so last year I heard two
years ago and kind of last year I gave a
lot of thought to this and have a paper
about it have talks I would you know
encourage you to go watch those if you
like but the idea here is that you know
I think data science should absolutely
start to adopt this more actively and
then I think the reason that we all are
so passionate this conference is that I
actually think that our studio and
specifically the tie Devers already are
doing this where it's like okay we kind
of have this opinion about how you
should structure your data but once you
sort of do the hard work of getting
things there then everything else is
easy and you can kind of reserve your
mental energy for the fun part of data
science so kind of going back you know
like I said this is this is like the
system I originally was thinking about
and then it's like okay actually like
tiding is this huge part of the system
and you zoom out more but what I want to
talk about now is that if you zoom out
even more from that like sure we're
focused on that last mile but actually
like the big part of doing data science
is actually getting data in the door
right and you hear about this more in
like the statistics world where it's
like study design and you know
collaborating with that but in the data
science world you really don't hear
about this much like people kind of talk
about like oh the data exists in this
database and what do you do with it then
but what I want to talk about now is
like I think that some of the biggest
wins I've seen in the data science world
are when a data scientist actually
thinks about this entire process and
kind of first you know getting QC with
the graphics like well first of all this
is again kind of designing a system and
then one thing that's nice about helping
you know kind of immediate win here is
that it if you're more involved with the
data collection process maybe you can
get the data in the door in a way that
it doesn't need to be tidying so much
right so if you help like develop the
schemas and everything that you
it's going into the data in the first
place like maybe you won't have to you
know spend 80% of your time doing this
boring task of cleaning it up but you
know that's kind of like one practical
benefit but I want to talk now about
some examples of stitch fix where I've
seen like thinking holistically about
this broader system rather than that
last mile the way is that that has
really transformed our business so kind
of going back to stitch fix I was saying
you know you create this style profile
you get five items and then you keep
what you want send back the rest but one
of the key problems or one of the key
challenges we are facing is that five
clothing items you know for a person in
some set amount of time like really
isn't that much so you know you get five
things and when you checkout like when
you decide what to buy or not we'll ask
you some questions about did it fit
right did you like the style etc but
like that's not that much data per
person and then that's further
exacerbated by the fact that when like
in fashion in general like like we're in
the era of fast fashion where an
individual clothing item won't be on the
racks like that long I mean you know
somewhere like like some of the really
fast fashion it's like a matter of weeks
and then you know for us it's a little
longer than that but still like it's not
you don't have one shirt usually last
seen for years and years so on top of
the fact that we're not getting much
data from people like the clothes are
turning over fast enough that like we
were not able to accumulate enough data
per person in order per person and per
clothing item to do some of the more
traditional matrix factorization other
machine learning approaches and so this
was like something that was on
apparently my colleague the person who
developed this Chris moody was talking
about the fact that like basically every
time someone new started on the stitch
fix team they would try to write some
sort of matrix factorization algorithm
to solve this problem and would always
fail and it was sort of this rite of
passage for like joining the team I'm
not exactly an effective use of people's
time but
to fix it and so at some point the idea
got tossed around of like well what if
we could get more of these style ratings
per clothing item obviously getting a
style rating from something in person is
the most effective like you can really
see all the details see how it fits on
you but you know the visual
representation of an item is a lot of
the style signal so there's no reason
why we couldn't get ratings on that and
so like I said my colleague Chris really
picked up this problem and essentially
people were like well what if we created
something like tinder for clothes where
you could just see a clothing item and
say do you like it or not and kind of
swipe right versus left so my colleague
Chris moody like spent a year doing
exactly that he built an application
first via Facebook and now it's on the
formal app called style shuffle where
you essentially see a clothing item and
can say whether or not you like it and
you can go through very quickly and rate
a ton of stuff and this was I mean to
say it was transformative as an
understatement I mean all of a sudden we
could do all of the matrix factorization
work that we've been wanting to do and
the amount we've learned from this brand
new data source has been you know
monumental one of the things that we've
learned is kind of like how our clothes
separating right like like what sorts of
styles are very polarizing from each
other and so one example this isn't a
blog post which I've linked that you
can't quite see there and is that like
kind of what you would call boho items
versus preppy items are very polarized
away from each other so those are like
very two different kind of vibes that
you would go for with your clothing and
so again like this is just one example
of the things we've learned and we've
you know been able to incorporate into
our entire recommender system but the
other thing that was really great about
this project was that it also enabled
like all sorts of new lines of
investigations not just for individual
items but like other people who were
wanting to zoom out and think about that
entire data system were able to start to
pursue their own kind of research topics
and so I was one of those people where
you know I saw that people were liking
these different themes of clothes and
kind of clusters
and so I wanted to know like okay like
individual items are clustering this way
but what about kind of the what's the
interaction effect between different
items like when you see an entire look
that is boho what's your reaction to
that versus the individual pieces and so
this was super fun because right when I
started thinking about this the are open
side group and I think I'm pronouncing
it right when I say your and from that a
postdoc with that group created this
rapper this our rapper for imagemagick
which is a way of kind of pasting images
together and so I was able to actually
using are and the kind of embeddings we
got from these machine learning models I
was able to actually identify a bunch of
like boho items and various different
kind of aesthetics and so this is me
like like I was able to use our to like
print out essentially like baseball
cards of different items and then me and
my colleague Natalia like went through
and actually created outfits from these
like empirically like these items that
we empirically saw were highly
polarizing in these different kind of
axes of the matrix factorization and so
I was able again using art to create
these images of outfits that I could
feed right back into that style shuffle
and get reactions to them so a this is
cool like data scientists creating
outfits that you know hundreds of
thousands of people are reading and B
that this is all using are so like are
is you know like impacting you know what
customers see stitch fix and then again
it's just like you know being able to
creatively think about the entire system
and what clients wants enabled a bunch
of new data science things that was much
more than that last mile so kind of in
the last five minutes like when I talk
about this sort of designing a system it
might it might seem intimidating to say
hey some of the biggest swings are just
like completely creating a new app that
has it's completely new data source and
like once you do that data science is
great but you know designing things like
this is not just this kind of mythical
mysterious thing it's actually a
discipline it's something that people
can learn
and there's a lot of writing on it so
this book is from nigel cross which was
he's one of the premier researchers on
design thinking in general and I've been
super inspired by reading his stuff and
thinking about this in general we've
talked about it a lot on the podcast but
just some like kind of basics about
design thinking it's a very
solution-focused discipline you're
constructively thinking so compared to
science where you're kind of diagnosing
and teasing apart problems and
understanding the root of the problem
design thinking is much more about
iterating toward a solution quickly
you're kind of using both your left and
right brain so your analytical mind and
your more like artistic mind and there's
some really interesting stuff around
like it is its own way of knowing it's
not it's a form of kind of rhetoric with
sketching and so it's not just like a
thing it's actually complete like like
the nigel cross talks about being is
this like third way of knowing there's
sort of art science and design and i saw
this quote from him early on and i just
thought it was so perfect for data
science work where it's like you know
design ability is one of these three
fundamental dimensions of human
intelligence design science and art form
in an not an or relationship to create
this incredible human cognitive ability
and so kind of like I feel like my
headline for this section is just you
know it's not the art of data science
it's not just the art of data science or
the science of data science but there's
also this huge aspect and I think in
some ways the most important aspect is
design thinking for data science so you
know in terms of like what to do now
this again this isn't just like
something you're born with it's not
magical there are ways to hone it and
cultivate it within yourself the biggest
one like if I were to give my kind of
instructions for what to do now there's
a bunch of really accessible reading on
this so in the podcast we went through
nigel cross one of his design thinking
books and this was a this was like a
photo from one of the podcast listeners
which i really closed so much there's
also i participated in a design sprint
at work and that was really that was
really effective so
something I would recommend as well
there's also this really great book
called designing your life which is
essentially applying design thinking to
like designing your life lack of a
better term so kind of thinking about
how you're spending your time and are
you like happy with you know the way
that you're like the the choices you've
made in your life so in terms of being
introduced to the concept it's like a
very personally applicable book so I
totally recommend it I think the other
one that's huge is like practicing
design thinking for data science
problems so in general even within the
design field they say the only way to
get good at this is to do it a lot so we
actually on the podcast talked a little
bit about this where most data science
problems are like you know here's the
data set do something with it but
instead I would encourage you to think
like here's an interesting problem I
want to solve and how would I even go
about like creating data set for this
and solving it we went through one with
like commute times so understanding the
variance of your commute times and it's
like okay how would you even measure
that reliably in a way that's like low
touch and so Roger actually we did this
on the podcast and Roger wrote like an
epic blog post about it weird like just
like kind of just describing the entire
process of coming up with it so I would
totally encourage you to read that or
try to think of things in your own life
and again it might be kind of contrived
but the point is to practice and then
finally and I wish I had a lot more time
to talk about this part but a huge part
of data science a huge part of design
thinking is having empathy for the user
so you know being able to understand
would people want to play this kind of
style shuffle game and just even like
for data science understanding what does
this person need like what sort of
analysis visualization says this person
need in order to be convinced of what I
think is the right conclusion from this
data and so you know if I wanted you to
walk away with one thing from this it's
that empathy is not some fixed character
trait it's actually something that you
can cultivate like it's a muscle muscle
you can strengthen JD talked about it
but meditation
is a huge way to do this and that's been
like personally very impactful for me
for cultivating empathy and so if you're
kind of like feeling hopeless about that
part I would just encourage you to
explore like there are ways to
strengthen this muscle so with that you
know thank you so much I don't think I
have time for questions but I appreciate
your time
[Music]